saying that my idea for the second part
of this projection was wrong and it's
invalidated and that's okay you know
this is the only way uh to move forward
sometimes you have to acknowledge that
you are wrong uh just remove all your
drawings and make a new plan and that's
the only way as a Trader to be
profitable
if you think that the market is wrong
and your ego is very big then you know
you don't want to be able to make money
in the long term in this game so
um you know that's fine we've been
nailing the market for quite some time
but sometimes a crystal ball gets cloudy
uh it's a joke anyway now we got this
part of operation right which was
Monday's first move to the upside okay
and we were expecting to be honest
continuation to the downside to fail
this week we've been talking about the
weekly psychological pattern with a
midweek reversal usually on Wednesday or
Thursday but I was betting on the idea
that we would see the reversal to the
upside on Thursday after we failed at
least the 50 of this week so that was my
idea obviously you can see that it
didn't play out because yesterday we saw
this pump from here
um I'll tell you you have to always keep
the good things and the good thing that
I get from this is that some followers
were telling me clip removable there are
some weeks in the one hour time frame
check it out uh you know this is very
positive because obviously means that
you guys are learning and this is also
what I plan I want to have a community
that is educated because sometimes I can
miss some things and then you guys can
tell me and I can check it out and we
help each other with the trading okay so
that's a good thing and you can see in
this one over here
what were the laws of this uh drop from
here you can see some wixster downside
here okay check those weeks but price is
not progressing any further and usually
when you say this it means that the
market maker doesn't have the intention
to continue pushing price lower and they
are building their lungs with this weeks
okay then you have this green candle
here okay take this one
you have this green candle here after
you seal these Wicks telling you okay
you know we're sifting out of this song
you know we're moving up so that would
be a good Zone to go long then from this
point if you notice they continue
pushing the price up uh now uh if you
check this uh there is something quite
similar okay we are so we're seeing
something very similar here if you check
this Zone you can see again all these
switch to the upside
okay but price is not continuing higher
why are they doing exactly the same
thing you know are they building shorts
now uh that's the only thing also we
have here the daily 50ma let's mark it
okay uh to the Daily 50ma it's around
27 677
um
could we see a stop run towards this
area
Maybe
uh why not okay but I'll tell you this
is looking pretty heavy it's looking
pretty heavy and I think they probably
are gonna drop from here uh if you check
here
this last candle okay now at the end
goes up you can see that the LA the week
goes below the previous ones okay so
that's another stop point now that's
what the only thing that it tells me
that we could see again
something similar okay
that it would be something like this but
with so many weeks to be honest uh now
the New York session is going to start
now in one hour
drop from here because if you notice
here you have some liquidity pools okay
you have this one that they are
recovering now but you also got uh this
one over here for example okay or even
here at the lows you have even this Zone
here okay so why not maybe we see
today's some kind of range
um they'd repeat again uh ideally I'm
gonna be waiting
okay because I haven't entered yet I
could have entered here to be honest
well I haven't entered yet so I'm gonna
wait until the New York session to see
what happens I'm gonna have an hour look
at the volar index at the liquidation
hit maps and make a plan okay first I
want to go to the dollar Index
because if you notice hang on let's go
back to bitcoin yesterday Bitcoin was
pumping from this is Wednesday at 2 p.m
okay let's go now to the rod index
the dollar Index if you notice is doing
the same it's going up so this is not
making any sense why is Bitcoin and the
dollar Index going up at the same time
look at this scandal in the dollar Index
okay uh it's not making much sense if
you if you notice to be honest uh I mean
let's check yesterday I mean to be
honest if you check yesterday too the
other index was uh retracing
okay so that could explain yesterday's
bitcoinfoom uh but now if you notice
Thursday
is being pumping okay it's pumped how
much is this
zero to fifty percent okay and if we go
to bitcoin again
let's see what Bitcoin is doing
Bitcoin is not dropping no no they're
holding in this Zone over here let's
find Thursday
uh so from here okay Bitcoin is still
holding so you have the lower index
going up a Bitcoin holding here so
that seems a bit weird to me okay
uh I'll try to figure that out
the normal thing to see here is to see
Bitcoin dropping so is this showing the
Bitcoin is you know has some strength at
the moment some momentum or is it just
some manipulation that's what I'm gonna
now check the liquidation rate Maps
let's have a look what we can find that
okay
really quickly to see if there is
something uh very interesting because
usually you see it looks quite messy
there is liquidity pretty much
everywhere but you can see the the there
is a yellow bar at 27 500. far enough
and if we go to the seven days time
frame
maybe this chart can tell us a bit more
information
okay you can see Call of liquidity at 27
800.
that's basically if you notice when this
bar goes more yellow okay it's us we are
you know hitting all these weeks of The
Upside it's like a resistance zone so
you can see how Traders are opening
shorts in this Zone over here
and there are liquidations right above
it so that's why it could execute a
stophunt okay maybe we can see a stop
and that's why I kind of dismiss the
idea even if it is even if it's looking
pretty heavy and we think you know it
might drop again I'll make a bad Simpson
pattern this is still a possibility that
we see a stop run today okay that's why
I would recommend to wait until the New
York session opens so if they set a
stophunt it is at a stophunt to 27 800
ish that will be right above the daily
then you want a quick rejection from
there okay
without leaving a week to the upside
because if they like if they live a week
to the upside that means the price will
go again to the 50 which then if you see
a quick and a reaction then you can
place for example a short limit order by
50 of the week and then price would
eventually go down and that's what at
least you would expect okay where to
potentially to the next liquidations 26
400 okay so let's wait until the New
York session that's my plan for today
okay
again it's not Financial advice that's
you know I'm trying to figure out what
plan I'm gonna do today
now if you go to the one month time
frame you can see that there was this
high at 30 30 000 again many weeks to
the upside
and price came down
I mean
so let me ask you a question could could
we be seeing exactly the same right now
you know this is obviously a higher time
frame
but maybe we're seeing the same right
now in lower time frame may we see now
price going down
okay
and then we're gonna come back up to the
Sun
okay so what do you mean that maybe now
we could for example go to I don't know
26 400.
and then push again to 27 800 why not uh
these are the kind of things you have to
think about because what happens in
lower time from Habits in high and
higher time frame on what happens here
higher time frame also happens in lower
time frame
and this looks pretty similar to what
we're seeing today in our time frame
okay doesn't mean that it's going to
play exactly the same that's why I'm
gonna go back to the charts now and see
if I can figure something out
yes I think that today
I'm gonna favor again shorts
um I'm gonna favor the idea
that we might be seeing
about Simpson pattern here
uh you know that's what I'm gonna favor
because I can see some imbalances over
here
okay
in this Zone in this Zone in this Zone
and this one that is gonna get filled
probably soon
uh but again if you for example see
something like this a drop okay here
and then we see a quick bounce
then that's gonna be a good moment to
think that maybe we see a stop hunt over
here
okay and then a drop
so that's pretty much what I have now in
my head
maybe to test the daily 50ma hopefully
we can see some kind of you know
deviation
like this
they can fit all these liquidations that
was on the seven day time frame and then
drop but for now it's looking pretty
heavy okay and all these weeks remind me
of what we saw for example here
okay or what we saw for example in this
Zone over here okay so be very careful I
recommend you guys or this is what I'm
doing at least wait until the New York
session starts
see with their intentions
if we see do I mean I want to be
obviously happy happier if we see a poem
first
because if we see a pump first this is
basically telling me that I can get a
better entry okay now if they start
dropping from here okay and we start to
lose these levels over here then yes you
can join here for example you can scalp
this Zone you can scrap this Zone
another take profit for example here but
obviously if they start pumping from
here then they couldn't take a position
here another one at 27 800 okay uh
and that would give you a better entry
for this potential move later okay so
that's what I'm keeping an eye on today
favoring lower price system okay
let me check the 50ma
in the one hour time frame where below
it okay uh uh see for example this is
what I mean if we test the 50ma and we
hold it then why not we could see
another push-up but if we go to the four
hour time frame
it's not looking that great because it
seems like we are losing okay we are
losing the the 15 I mean still we got
uh would say 2 hours and 45 minutes for
this Scandal to finish
uh so I'm gonna guide myself more with
the one or time frame for now
because that for our time frame candle
has started okay so I'm gonna keep an
eye on the 50 I mean the daily in the
one hour time frame sorry if we can hold
here okay and we see some kind of these
moves you know then price to then the
50ma should continue pushing price
higher maybe then we can see our lovely
a stophunt we can enter in the stophunt
and then drop okay uh so that's what I'm
keeping an eye on
hang on
uh this actually we haven't recovered
this week have we
sorry let me check this
uh we haven't we haven't actually
recovered this week and the top of the
week matches with the daily 50 I mean so
that would be for example
that would be my entry point if we see a
stop point I would definitely enter here
uh 27 665 ish because you have here the
daily 50ma the 100 of the week that
could be a good reversal and if we see
you know a spike up
over here then there will be another
good entry point to hit all those
liquidations but that's only in the case
that we see New York
holding the 50
EMA in the one hour time frame which is
this purple line
you know and then that could give you
the idea that we're gonna see the
stockhold otherwise if we lose this and
we'll test their resistance then yes
price do not going lower I'm feeling
these imbalances
over here
so I think that this is a good setup for
today
we have you know about around 45 minutes
is to start to see some action in the
charts say their intentions if the one
or 50ma holds
then get ready for the stophunt if we
lose it get ready for these imbalances
that's
today's Bitcoin analysis in a nutshell
okay it depends on the 50ma
potential supplement
or
retrace these liquidity pools
so thank you so much guys for watching
and I'll see you soon